It's about the right collaborators walking into the room together. Isn't it?
It is. Like opera. It's a collaborative art form.
All these many talented craftsmen, I say talented because every profession you have to know
what you're doing. You have to prepare. You have to get there.
But all these people that come together, the chemistry has to work.
And how do you make the chemistry work?
Well, I'm not going to say it's a marriage or a family,
But for the moments that you're together,
it's a marriage and a family. Righ?
For those moments, you're only together for moments.
But tolerance, give a little, all of that kind of stuff goes into movie making.
And when it comes together, the final thing is if they don't like it, you know, move on.
In 1977, I hate to jump around, but in 77, when.
William Friedkin says, I want the guy, they did the Rocky movie to conduct the Academy Award show.
I didn't have a clue about how to do that show.
I had to go to Henry Mancini, Johnny Williams, Elmer Bernstein,
the people who had previously conducted that show.
This whole thing is a TV show. It began in the 50s.
There is a format for the show. Music, I'm talking about the music.
I can only speak about music.
When they say the winner is, you play the theme from the show that just won.
And have been doing this since the 50s.
I began in the 70s. 77 was the first time and I did it a number of times
Up until whatever the last time I did it... A lot of years.
So the melody comes in and you have to prepare for each of the five nominees in each category.
Costume design, five movies, five themes. Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
You put them on the paper for the musicians to go...
The winner is and they play the correct one.
But I'm talking about the music.
Over the years, you can't find a theme, for the movie.
The Closer you get to this current period, you go,
Now the movie is from, I can't mention movies because I can't remember,
but there's a lot of movies with no theme. There's sound design.
There's cans rattling. There's things that happen that go WOOSH.
And they say, well, the winner is and you go WHOOSH.
Why? Because that's the only thing they played in the movie.
So that concept of playing the winner, has evolved or devolved,
into what do we do? What do we play when they win?
We can't find a melody and many of the scores.